meetings industry is so important to las  vegas  it is the real driver of our mid-week  and certainly after  the two years of the pandemic  i think the entire city the entire  industry  realizes how important meetings are  not just for the economy of the  destination  but for the business that's transacted  at those meetings for all the companies  the exhibitors who come  so we're excited to highlight the  industry again  and we're really excited to see it  coming back  those businesses need to get back to  work they need to  meet new customers they need to meet new  suppliers and being able to get together  is the way to do that and you can see it  in the meetings that are happening they  have told us that the meetings when  they've come back have been some of the  most productive get-togethers that  they've had